>>Sparky: Welcome to the Android Developer
Office Hours.
[someone whistles]
>>Sparky: We are your Android EMEA Developer
Relations team.
I'm Sparky in Munich, Germany.
I'm also joined by Matt and Rich and Nick
in London, UK.
We're here to answer any questions that you
have regarding any topics around Android development.
We won't answer any questions about unannounced
things.
But barring our refusal to look into the future,
we're here to talk about whatever interests
you regarding Android development.
So let's see who's in the Hangout and what's
goin' on.
>>Rich: Well, we're here Sparky.
Hey, good to see you again.
We've changed rooms this week as you may have
noticed.
It's not just a faulty camera, our room's
turned blue.
We're in Haskell instead of the standard Android
room.
>>Sparky: Haskell?
[inaudible]
>>Rich: [unintelligible] I'm shoppin' around
here.
>>Sparky: Oh, oh.
Well, we don't talk about future product directions
do we, so?
[laughter]
>>Rich: Yes, this is the Haskell room, soon
it will be [inaudible]
>>Sparky: We, we emphatically deny that Haskell
is going to be the future of Android.
[laughter]
>>Rich: Please deny that a lot.
I don't want to have to learn that.
[laughter]
Just 'cause we got the ball rolling.
>>Nick: It worked out quite well today.
'cause I've got an Android t-shirt and Matt's
got a Google TV t-shirt.
So we're quite clearly product [inaudible]
[laughter]
Who knows about Richard's.
Bit of everything.
>>Rich: I just do IO.
It's fine.
Bright here, as well.
Interesting.
Well, better lit than normal.
So, yeah.
>>Nick: Who else is live in the Hangout?
Who do we have?
>>Rich: Hey Johann, good to see you there?
>>Johann: Hi guys.
[clears throat]
>>Rich: You alright?
Is that actually your office now?
I don't think you've called in from your office
before.
>>Johann: No, that's true, that's true.
It's the office.
>>Rich: Nice.
[laughter]
>>Rich: I've just bought my ticket for DroidCon
Holland, so I'll be seeing you out there in
November.
>> Johann: Good, good, good, good.
>>Rich: Quite looking forward to it.
>>Johann: That's good.
Yeah.
>>Rich: You can [inaudible] us coming up already.
>>Matt: I'm already on it.
>>Rich: Oh, yeah, that's right, you're speaking
at DroidCon Holland.
>>Matt: Yeah.
>>Rich: There you go, you've got two of us
heading there already.
I don't know that Nick is going to DroidCon
UK?
Are you going to DroidCon UK?
You're speaking at DroidCon UK, aren't you?
>>Matt: Yep.
I'm working my way 'round.
>>Rich: So both of those guys will be at DroidCon
UK and us guys will be, and maybe Nick as
well, will join us at DroidCon Holland.
>>Nick: Maybe.
>>Johann: Very good.
>>Rich: Looking forward to the DroidCon Season.
>>Johann: Yeah.
>>Rich: Good chance to get back and see all
the developers.
Who else is on the Hangout today?
We've got Ravi?
Hey there Ravi.
Do you have, um--?
>>Nick: Where are you phoning in from Ravi?
>>Rich: Can you have a microphone today?
Or are you just on chat?
>>Nick: Well, we can't hear you right now.
>>Rich: Yeah.
>>Ravi: Uh, can you hear me now?
>>Nick: Yes we can.
>>Ravi: Yeah.
Um.
>>Nick: Nice fat dings
>>Ravi: Yeah, can you hear me now?
>>Sparky: Yes, we can hear you.
>>Ravi: Yeah.
OK.
Um, I just have some questions about audio.
Handling audio in Android.
>>Male #1: [inaudible] this morning [inaudible]
about KPI [inaudible]
>>Rich: Uh, one second Ravi.
Because.
[multiple people talking, background noise]
>>Rich: That should be [inaudible].
Sorry, carry on Ravi.
[man talking indistinctly in background]
>>Ravi: OK.
[inaudible] take longer than [rustling noise].
So I've been working on audio in Android.
So I've got this stream, which I'm doing streaming
soundtrack.
Streaming to the headphones.
Are you clear so far?
>>Nick: Yeah.
>>Rich: Yeah, yeah.
>> Nick: [inaudible] is just about a half
hour, so.
>>Ravi: And now what I just need is another
audio track or maybe a sound tool, which sends
the audio to a speaker only, which means that
the headphones signal will be uninterrupted.
And the SoundPool, which sends to the speakers
would be an independent one.
Is there any way to do this?
>>Matt: I think I catch you.
So you, are you trying to play a sound through
the speakers as well as the headphones at
the same time.
>>Ravi: Yeah.
Different.
>>Rich: Different sounds?
I don't think that's actually physically possible.
>>Ravi: I've been trying through using AudioTrack
which sends a sound, a continuous sound through
speakers, I'm sorry, headphones.
And I've been using SoundPool to use this
as an audio manager.
Using an audio manager stream ring.
Do you get it?
>>Sparky: Yeah.
We've had some questions like this before.
I think the first thing I would ask is, why
do you want to do that?
I mean, I think that one of the strongest
use-cases for headphones is that you don't
play sound out through the speakers.
So, I mean, you know, it seems like you have
the possibility of circumventing the basic
contract that the device makes that says when
you plug in your headphones you won't be annoying
your neighbors.
[male voices in background] [door slams]
>>Ravi: Mm-hm.
But the thing is here, we are actually sending
the entire audio input signal as in one source,
while the other one we're using has maybe
more [unintelligible]stuff . When we use a
notification on the ring, [inaudible] in a
stream, it's interrupting the stream to wait.
And in this audio's finished, and then it
returns the signal back again.
Which is quite, not what we are expecting
to do.
[someone comments in background, inaudible]
>>Sparky: I don't think, I don't know if any
of us are really that expert in the multimedia
framework.
I don't know, maybe, I won't speak for you
guys in London.
I mean, technically I don't know the answer.
I'm just not convinced that it's a good idea.
Maybe you guys in London have a perspective
on this.
>>Rich: Well, I think we'd know about it if
it was possible.
'Cause you'd end up setting separate volume
controls for the speaker, to the headphones.
And you know, when you, there's events that
happen when you plug in headphones and unplug
them for example.
The music will stop playing.
So I know that you can get events to tell
you that event's been plugged in but then
[inaudible] speakers.
Probably confuse users somewhat as well, 'cause
they would be expecting the speakers to mute
as soon as they plugged in the headphones.
Could be potentially embarrassing.
I'm guessing it's just not possible.
>>Ravi: Mm.
>>Sparky: Or if it is possible, maybe the
way to do it is to do it in the NDK.
You know, once you get below the Java framework,
then you can get much more direct control
over the actual hardware devices and you might
be able to open electrical audio channels
that might just might not be possible to populate
at the NDK, or at the framework level.
>>Rich: Sounds like a good question to try
on StackOverflow and see if you get any response.
>>Ravi: I'm already in a discussion with StackOverflow.
>>Rich: OK.
Great.
If you want you can post a
>>Ravi: Yeah, so.
>>Rich: Question in the chat window and we'll
have a look at it as well.
>>Sparky: Did you also, are you the poster
of the questions in the Moderator as well?
>>Ravi: Yeah.
>>Sparky: OK.
>>Ravi: Android Boy.
>>Sparky: Good.
Yeah, I gave about the same response in the
Moderator that I just told you.
I wanna thank you for coming into the Hangout
and to let us consider your question live.
That's great.
That's what we're here for.
>>Ravi: Mm-hm.
>>Ravi: Thank you very much.
>>Rich: Yeah, thank you, thank you.
>>Sparky: Does anyone else want to jump in
with a question.
>>Male #2: Hi.
I wrote a question down on the chat bar.
But I wanted to know if, I just wanted to
see if we were able to use Google credentials
inside of Android.
>>Sparky: You mean like Open OPS?
Or Open—
[background feedback throughout]
>>Male #2: Yeah.
I'm using OPS.
I'm using the account manager to get an OPS
token.
And then I want to use Google credentials
in order to fetch data from the, from I don't
know, from contacts or from calendar and so
on.
And—
>>Nick: So, yes there is a good way, and it's
coming soon.
>>Male #2: OK.
>>Nick: And basically we're working on a new
file library [inaudible] Right now it's [inaudible].
[audio cutting out and interfering noises]
Anything, you can try that.
>>Male #2: Yes.
>>Nick: Android.
You watch that [inaudible] So your API is
going to write for an app.
So you can get up to speed [inaudible] 'cause
when you [inaudible.].
So that would be, I think now.
>>Male #2: OK.
And for now, is there a workaround or something?
Besides the Google Java API?
>>Nick: Well, yeah, you still can use like
O Authors and C Scape [inaudible]
>>Rich: I put the link in the chat for you.
[feedback continues]
>>Male #2: Oh, OK.
I just saw that now.
>>Nick: [inaudible] the API.
>>Rich: Yeah.
[inaudible] authorization.
>>Nick: So, in the side bar, the chat bar,
do you see that Rich has put a couple of links.
Yeah?
>>Male #2: Yeah.
>>Nick: It's that [unintelligible] I just
mentioned.
And at first there's an example of [inaudible]
using the Google Tasks API which [inaudible]
>>Male #2: OK.
GoogleTasks will also be the one, the example
one that I can use and switch to, I don't
know, to get contacts, get calendar events
and so on?
>>Nick: Yeah, you would have to use different
scopes.
Different [unintelligible] scopes.
>>Male #2: Yeah.
>>Nick: To collect data.
But yeah, it's the basic steps.
>>Male #2: OK.
Thank you.
>>Rich: Right.
>>Nick: [unintelligible] in the comments in
the G Plus links.
>>Rich: Yeah.
That's right.
So, I will check the situation.
There it is.
Google Tasks.
Or is this Google?
>>Nick: Did we have any more live questions
to people in the Hangout?
>>Sparky: We've got a pretty full house here.
>>Rich: Yeah.
>>Sparky: So, looks like Talid has joined
us but I don't see him.
>>Nick: Richard, go ahead.
Please ask away.
Feel free to either speak it if you can or
type it in the sidebar.
>>Matt: [inaudible]
>>Sparky: Does anyone want to ask a question
while Richard is typing or should we take
one from the Moderator?
>>Rich: What happened to users dynamic fragments?
>>Sparky: Yeah.
[chuckles] Let's jump in with one from the
Moderator.
Here's, this should be a quick one.
Orin in Israel wants to know, is it possible
to show the in-app billing dialog.
The Google Play in-app billing in landscape
mode instead of portrait?
Um, I suggested that he run one of those utilities
that forces the entire device to landscape
and see what happens.
That'll probably work.
I think that, when possible, the Android team
tries to make its activities orientation agnostic
and support rotation.
And if they don't support it by default on
a particular device, it's probably because
they weren't able to get a user experience
that they were happy with in that orientation.
And so they locked it out.
That's, so my guess there is that if they
don't support landscape on the Galaxy Nexus
it's because they weren't happy with the UX
that they got when they tried it.
>>Rich: I thought it was already done, to
be honest.
Um, I've seen it appear in landscape on multiple
devices.
Now, certainly on the Nexus 7 it appears in
landscape.
Maybe there are some smaller screened handsets
that they still haven't got a landscape layout.
>>Nick: [inaudible] version not [inaudible]
>>Rich: No, it was there from IO, I've seen
it.
But no, there's nothing you can do to force
There were versions of the market client that
would only show in portrait mode which was
annoying.
And they are updating.
Yeah, the ones that we have here are showing
in landscape.
I'm just concerned that maybe he's testing
on a smaller screen device, like, just—
>>Matt: Yeah.
>>Sparky: It's the Galaxy Nexus.
>>Rich: Yeah?
Well on Galaxy Nexus it should already be
done.
>>Sparky: I'm never sure of what everyone
else is seeing on the Galaxy Nexus.
'Cause I'm usually running some hairy dog-food
build that's you know, several steps removed
from what any sane person would dare to load
on their only device.
>>Matt: Living life on the edge.
>>Sparky: OK, we have a question from Richard.
"I'm trying to implement the Up button for
the tablet version which has dual pane layout.
All the fragments in the dual pane layout
share an activity and implement an interface."
Um.
Up button.
Well, I mean you don't need the up button
if you're just changing, say, fragments on
the same activity.
The up affordance is for changing between
activities.
Generally speaking when you have a dual pane
layout, right, you've got a selector in one
fragment and your detail in the other fragment.
And we don't really do like, we don't do back
history and that.
And we don't do navigation history and that.
Navigation is for changing activities.
Is that about right, Nick?
>>Nick: So I'm going to interpret this question
as you have like layers of hierarchy and navigation.
But instead of having separate activities
it sounds like you just have one activity
and you just dynamically change the content
of that one activity depending on which layer
of navigation you're at there.
That's how I interpret it.
That you've done so differently.
>>Sparky: OK.
>>Nick: So it sounds like you're trying to
almost, take control of what you [inaudible]
activities [inaudible].
Uh.
Which [inaudible] a little bit.
You know, it's timing your control.
You just click on an option item, select it
[inaudible]
[someone in the hangout speaking, inaudible]
So, you can just kind of react to it as that,
or if you use the latest, the later version
of the support library.
Um, if you wrote to the activities you can
provide a metadata tag, saying "Defining the
name of the parent activity" so that it will
handle the up button popping the stack and
reproducing the parent.
So that could work.
But I'm not quite sure what the exact question
[unintelligible] is.
[laughter]
>>Sparky: I suppose, to, taking what you said
there and running with it a little bit.
If he's swapping out fragments rather than
changing the activity, then you want no parent
activity.
And you just wanna receive that menu event
that option menu event and handle it by changing
out the fragment instead of—
>>Nick: I would caveat that there are some
places where the up button's kind of overloaded.
And doesn't just do navigation.
So I think a good example there is the expand-collapse
pattern.
Which is probably best demonstrated by Gmail.
Where if you're reading am message, kind of
in landscape.
And then you go to portrait.
The message expands to take up the entire
width of the screen and hides the kind of
sidebar with the list of messages.
And in that instance you might use the up
button there to create and out for the content.
So it's not always just kind of hierarchical
navigation.
>>Sparky: Hm.
>>Nick: Just to complicate things.
>>Sparky: Right.
>>Nick: But yeah, is that your question?
Is that, how do you literally react to it,
say?
In which case it's the on-option item selected
on the Android.ab.home isn't it?
Yeah.
It's in the action bar docs.
>>Sparky: Right, and while we're on the topic.
In the cases where you have that slide-in,
that slide-in control panel on the left side.
Like in the YouTube app.
>>Nick: Yep.
>>Sparky: Our guidance there is to not implement
that if there's any parent activity.
Right?
That's only for top portal activities with
no parent.
>>Nick: Yeah.
Correct.
>>Rich: OK, so whilst two people are typing,
we'll have a quick look at the Moderator.
There's a few questions in the Moderator from
Markus that actually came through for our
session last week, but then got answered at
the Mountain View low-level media session.
So the top one was how to detect if the audio
codec was for AMR wideband on a certain device.
They got to the point where they could detect
whether a device supported AMR, but not whether
it was wideband or narrow band.
So they didn't answer for that one.
And we're looking into what you could find
out about that.
>>Nick: I think that got answered in the Mountain
View when James Dong was there.
>>Rich: Yeah.
>>Nick: Um, but interesting on this one—
>>Rich: I thought James had some more information
on it.
>>Nick: No, you should stick with that.
>>Rich: OK.
>>Nick: But interestingly, one thing I did
see today in my streams, is ACRA.
If any of you out there are using the Android
crash reporting system.
It's quite a handy little system lots of people
are using.
For catching core exceptions and sending them
to Google Spreadsheet.
There's a new thing that Kevin, is it?
The, is that it?
Uh.
Can't remember his name.
I think it's Kevin.
Has added a protocol action on Jellybean devices,
also report back all the codecs.
And the device you're experiencing crash on
supports.
So if you're having this kind of media stuff,
and you're using acra, I'd encourage you to
take a look at that so you get a bit more
debug information about, oh, the device doesn't
support it or whatever.
So, definitely worth looking into.
>>Rich: Alright.
Do you wanna have a go at the next question
in the moderator, Sparky?
>>Sparky: Um, let's see.
What is the next question in the Moderator.
[laughs]
>>Rich: Ah.
>>Sparky: The next one I see is one about
SQL.
>>Rich: OK.
>>Sparky: OK.
So this says, oh wait.
No, actually, the one I see before that is
"How would a malicious Android keyboard be
treated in the Google Play Store?"
Well, if you know of a malicious keyboard,
you should go into your Google Play Store
application and flag it as inappropriate.
And then that'll be escalated to the Google
Play team.
When the Google Play team finds applications
that are misbehaving, they are suspended.
And in extreme cases the developer may be
banned and his account can be blocked.
So we don't treat lightly malware in the application
store.
>>Rich: No.
And malware keyboards could be potentially
really, really bad of course.
'cause they could read everything you're typing.
>>Nick: Be careful of any keyboard asking
for friends app permissions.
>>Rich: Be careful of anything asking for
friends app permissions.
I would totally agree with that.
If you want to provide more detail on your
error report, instead of opening the Google
Play client on your handset, and reporting
it as inappropriate, if you go to Google Play
Help on the web, we have a nice form that
you can fill in there.
To report inappropriate apps.
And you can just Google for Google Play Inappropriate
Apps and it comes up straight away.
You can click on that and fill in the details.
And it just gives our team a little bit more
to go on.
When they're trying to figure out why you
think it's malicious.
OK.
Let's take that one off.
Anyone else in the hangout have any questions
before we jump to the next--?
>>Nick: Who is that with the scariest avatar
face there?
>>Matt: Yes.
>>Rich: Yeah, thank you Ben S. for having
a really scary avatar.
>>Nick: Yeah.
I think you know exactly who it was typing,
straight away.
[laughter]
>>Rich: Benedicta.
It's me.
Same question here.
Its SQL.
Ah.
>>Sparky: OK then, well, let's answer it.
>>Rich: [unintelligible]
>>Nick: Do you wanna ask it live then?
>>Rich: Do you have a microphone there.
I'm guessing not.
>>Nick: Everyone must get bored of seeing
us chatter on.
>>Sparky: [laughs]
>>Rich: He's typing.
At the same time I'll check the—
>>Sparky: OK.
He's got a lot of background.
Well, thank you for muting then.
We appreciate that.
[laughter]
OK.
"I'm creating an app where the user enters
some value daily and I store it to SQL eight.
That should work offline, but, if the user
has multiple devices, his data should be synchronized.
Instant, not necessarily.
What's the best way to do this?"
Um, this says to me, you want a Google app
engine app up there.
And you should be syncing data up there to
your app engine.
What do you guys think.
>>Nick: Or, Google Drive.
I would do, whenever I did, might be to use
Google Drive and a sync adapter.
So you could have a sync adapter to periodically
call the drive API to sync up somewhere.
So if you don't wanna go down the route of
having to maintain your own storage service,
which is what the app engine side would be
doing, you could ask the user to store it
in their Google Drive folder or Drop Box or
something.
>>Sparky: Yeah, well if you're going to go
there then you don't even need SQL, do you?
I mean you could write rows into a spread
sheet or something, couldn't you?
Can we do that with the drive API?
>>Nick: Yes.
>>Sparky: Cool.
>>Nick: Yeah, and that's right actually, we
talked about the talk earlier on, which Rich
even linked to earlier on, about using Google
Drive from Android.
So if you take a look at that talk from Google
IO, it's exactly that.
It takes the notepad application, which many
of you might have used.
You might have worked through that sample
code as a first time resource SQL like database.
And it takes that and every time you save
a note in, so not every time.
But it has a sync adapter, just what you want.
So it periodically backs up that database.
It just inserts and updates.
To Google Drive backed up files.
So you can have it on multiple devices.
All in sync.
And it handles checking MP5 hashes to make
sure you were there.
[inaudible] and all that good stuff.
>>Sparky: That's pretty cool.
I've written a, I've written a Google Drive
app that tied a spreadsheet t to a web app.
But I've never done it on Android before.
So, maybe I should tried that next.
>>Nick: Yeah.
Fun to be had.
[chuckles]
>>Sparky: Right, uh, let's see, next.
Oh, my world is upside down.
I'm living on the bleeding edge here, I just
updated to Mountain Lion and all my scroll
bars are backwards.
[laughter]
>>Rich: It took me a good week to get used
to but it's worth persevering with.
'Cause now everyone else's scroll bars are
backwards.
[laughter]
>>Sparky: Yeah, yeah, I don't know how many
years I've been using scroll bars where you
mouse down to scroll up.
And—
>>Rich: Every mouse move has run down, every
scroll bar has run—except the ones on my
callback.
>>Sparky: But actually, I kinda like it this
way.
Because now, because you know, since I'm using
a track pad instead of a mouse, then now,
my, well, my laptop works exactly the same
as my tablets.
So.
>>Rich: Yes.
Exactly.
>>Sparky: So it's all good.
>>Rich: That's why it feels a bit more natural.
>>Sparky: Huh.
>>Rich: OK.
There was a question.
"I am a user but I have a problem.
From NDBJR.
In, from nowhere actually.
It doesn't have a location.
>>Nick: Aw.
>>Rich: OK.
"The system pop-up, about Google authentication
apparently.
The pop-up only stays up for one second and
contains too much info to discern.
Where can I find the message to look at longer?"
Is this, wow, I can't really ask you 'cause
you're not in the hangout.
Uh, we need a bit more information on that
before we can answer the question.
It's whether, if you're developing an application
and you're seeing this pop up, then it should
be up until you approve it.
So, I don't know what you're doing to override
the pop-up and make it disappear.
But as Sparky mentioned in the Moderator,
check your log CAT and see what's actually
happening to make that pop-up disappear.
Because our authentication screen should be
dialogs that come up for quite a long time
and let you accept or deny them or approve.
NTK.
Oops.
>>Sparky: Hm. Paul Hanson has a question.
"Regarding NFC.
I'm missing the ability to card emulate.
Is there a way to do this to beam?"
Um, I mean, there is some sort of a card emulation
feature isn't—I mean, there's an API for
it.
It's in NFC extras.
I looked this up just earlier today for somebody
else.
Maybe I can find that for you.
I don't know exactly what it means, I just
know that there's an API to turn it on.
I guess it's needed for some of the e-commerce
related applications.
>>Nick: Yeah, I think we have very limited
card emulation.
>>Sparky: OK.
>>Rich: OK.
So it looks like actually the rest of the
Moderator questions have already been dealt
with.
In last week.
Unless you—In there Sparky that we haven't
answered.
>>Sparky: Shouldn't be.
No.
I think we've got a few, actually.
Let me take a look at this.
Um.
Let's see.
Keyboard SQL.
AudioCodec.
Um, there's one from Markus about encoding.
Was that also in the detailed session last
week?
'Cause I didn't, or in the Mountain View session?
'Cause I answered it but I didn't know—
>>Rich: What was the question.
>>Sparky: That—
>>Rich: Oh, [unintelligible]
>>Sparky: All these ones from Markus have
they all been answered before?
>>Rich: I think so.
They did mention quite a few questions from
Markus.
>>Sparky: OK.
>>Rich: But he's still there.
>>Sparky: Well, I can answer it anyway.
He says "How can I encode media that is not
from camera or microphone?
Or how can I decode something without also
outputting it?"
Um, search StackOverflow.
There's lots of examples of people who have
done this.
[laughter]
I mean, that's—
>>Nick: And then you can go look at the new
MediaCodec classes.
Um, introduced in Jellybean.
>>Rich: Yeah, if you want to encode it for
Jellybean I'd always look at MediaCodec.
'cause that's awesome.
Um, although, it's much better at the moment
in decoding than it is in encoding.
Also, if you want to do it over a wider variety
of formats and platforms.
FFMPEG is always a good group to check out.
OK.
So does anyone in the Hangout have anything
else to ask?
>>Sparky: Um, if you guys can stall for a
minute I will find that note that I sent about
the NFC API.
>>Nick: Uh, there's one live question that's
come in on the G plus post.
"Do you guys recommend a good way the usage
tests for Android applications like Selenium?"
Any favorite testing approaches?
>>Rich: Oh, auto testing.
Or—
>>Nick: Yeah.
>>Matt: Or [unintelligible]
>>Nick: [inaudible]
>>Rich: Yeah, there's a couple out there that,
roboelectrics slash roboting combination.
There's one that a lot of people talk about
>>Nick: [inaudible] The unit tests.
>>Rich: Johann.
How do you test your Android apps?
Put you on the spot.
>>Johann: [chuckles] Currently, currently
not.
[laughter]
>>Rich: Excellent.
>>Johann: I've, I'm currently working on an
app which needs the Wi-Fi, so and that's not
available in the emulator.
And I, I know the robotium can test a real
device as well, but at the time when I made
the decision, so I'm more in the project now,
so—
>>Rich: Well, OK.
One suggestion.
At Google IO we had a Talks partner in called
TestDroid.
It's a product called TestDroid by Bitbar.
And they do a really nice thing.
They have a system where they let you record
your entire test on the device using key presses
whatever focuses.
And then records it as a script, it uploads
it to their cloud.
Where they then replay it across any number
of devices that you'd like.
And they have like 100 varieties of Android
devices up there.
And they photograph the screens for you and
they do all the touch presses and everything.
Automated in their cloud.
So you can run, you can choose exactly which
devices you want to run it on.
And you can just go and say "I want the Motorola
Droid One, I want Sony X, and Xperia.
Whatever.
Ark.
Maybe.
And a Galaxy Nexus and a Nexus 7."
And submit.
And it just runs through.
Runs them all for you.
And it seems like a pretty cost effective
way of being able to test your application
on a number of devices.
Which they're working on integrating that
into people's project build flows.
[Hangout dings] So that at the end of each,
so you can sanity check, basically, as you're
doing your builds, that will automatically
upload, and run the tests.
So there are other services out there.
>>Matt: Trying to think if there may be one
way you can actually get access to a live
device with a video camera on top of it.
>>Rich: That would be [inaudible]
>>Nick: [inaudible]
>>Matt: [inaudible]
>>Rich: [inaudible] when I was at DroidCon
last year.
>>Matt: I've got a Testdroid [unintelligible]
that I remember from DroidCon.
[Hangout dings]
>>Rich: I'd like to finish all of them.
If you Google TD services.
Also—
>>Matt: MonkeyRun [inaudible]
>>Rich: MonkeyRun and stuff like that.
Yeah.
It might be MonkeyRun scripts that Testdroid
uses.
Um.
>>Matt: OK.
>>Rich: And I think it was Samsung which opened
up their own online testing lab free for developers
if you sign up for Samsung Developer.
Was that Samsung or Sony, Nick?
>>Nick: Samsung had an online legend, Sony
had a [inaudible]
>>Rich: [inaudible] devices.
So you can go to the OEM developer sites as
well.
Alright, it sounds like you can borrow devices
from Sony and Samsung is a bit like Testdroid.
The one that you mentioned.
[all speak together]
Device [inaudible]
>>Rich: Where you can go online and [crashing
sound] the device.
>>Nick: If you're using Selenium, I'd probably
check out [inaudible] as my first tool.
>>Rich: Yes.
[door closing sound]
>>Johann: Well, Rich, to put a question back
to you then.
Um how do you test apps which use like a server,
server side back end?
Do you, and which might be intermittent or
so, do you mock that out?
Yeah.
>>Rich: Yeah, if it was gonna be like a high
grade application that needed testing, that
was being built as a contract work.
Then yeah.
I would mock it out as I was building the
application so I could run through the tests
and make sure I was happy with the server
side component.
And then test the server side and run it separately
and bring it all together.
>>Johann: Yeah.
>>Rich: Can't say that I ever actually went
to those lengths.
[laughs] 'Cause I just build the applications
for myself.
And as is often the way with Android, we test
on our users.
Users are pretty eager to give feedback at
Android, right?
>>Johann: Yeah.
[chuckles]
>>Matt: Um, there was a, uh, thing that you
posted up a long while ago, Nick.
About being [unintelligible] like a beta.
APK, and we're disputing it.
It's kind of [inaudible]
>>Nick: [indistinct] is the popular one these
days.
[inaudible]
>>Rich: A few of those as well.
>>Matt: Yeah, [unintelligible] doin' it.
>>Sparky: So, apropos of testing on your users,
I will give a piece of advice.
Which is, don't do live user testing for your
negative test cases.
"Oh my God, you just deleted my entire album!"
[laughter] "Yeah, I know, it was supposed
to do that.
Success."
[laughter]
>>Rich: OK, did you find that thing, Sparky?
>>Sparky: I did.
I just posted into the file that implements
the functions for card emulation.
For turning on and off card emulation is called
"NFCadapterextras.Java" and I found it in
the AOSP just by Googling on the file names.
So that's what I suggested that Paul do.
So.
I don't have like documentation for what exactly
it does or how to use it or anything.
Just, you know, somebody asked "Can you do
a card emulation?" and the answer is "Evidently,
yes."
>>Rich: I think it's pretty limited as well.
>>Sparky: Yeah.
>>Rich: Unfortunately.
>>Sparky: Alright.
Looks like Yossi's going away.
So, farewell to Yossi.
Does anyone else have an issue they want to
bring up?
>>Richard: Yeah, I'd just like to follow up
on my issue earlier.
>>Rich: Hey, Richard.
>>Richard: Hi there.
>>Sparky: There's two of you.
[laughter]
>>Richard: I jumped on another machine.
I thought it might be easier if I jumped on
in person.
To try to find a quiet spot.
>>Nick: [inaudible] So you had the issue with
the dynamic fragments, right?
>>Richard: Yeah.
So I've got, um, an app.
I've got the sort of, seems to be working
fine for the sort of mobile version.
The tablet version, I have sort of a search
list and then when somebody performs a search,
they get a list of results that slides in
and then when they sort of click on a result
it then slides in the detail screen.
And that will then allow them to slide in
a more detailed screen.
Again after that.
So I wanted to do something like the Gmail
app.
Which then allows you to sort of navigate
back upwards.
[Hangout dings]
>>Sparky: Mm.
Right, so maybe the little up button would
simply close the rightmost tab essentially?
Or close the rightmost detail view?
>>Rich: I apologize for that Richard.
We dropped out just as you were saying about
the fourth list that drops in.
Our Hangout dropped out for a second there.
>>Richard: That's fine.
So it just goes to results list and then a
summary detail screen and then goes into a
more detailed screen.
And I'm just looking to do something like
the Gmail app where you just hit the back
button, it would take you from the very detailed
screen to the detailed screen, up to the search
results, then up to the search screen.
>>Rich: Mm-hm.
>>Richard: So I've kinda got out a structure.
All my for the tablet layout, all the fragments
are sort of contained within a search activity.
And all the fragments implement and interface
that calls back to that—
[video cuts out]
>>Richard: that will do all the fragment transactions
and swap out all the screens appropriately.
Now, where I'm having the issue is, is obviously
for the initial top level search screen, I
don't want the up button on that screen.
I just want it in all the sort of child screens.
So because everything shares the one activity,
it's a, what is the best way of having, specify
I want the up button to be there for every
screen except for that top level screen?
And then b, how do I handle the view suppressing
the up button?
That those are the two problems that I'm facing.
>>Sparky: Well, you can show and hide that
chevron, right?
I mean that's a function call.
A method.
Which I recall.
>>Nick: Yeah, it's [unintelligible]
>>Sparky: It seems to me like what you just
wanna do is know your, sort of know your depth
of view.
And anytime your depth is greater than one,
close the rightmost fragment and decrease
your depth.
That's kind of, I mean, it sounds like a pat
answer.
But that's what I'm seeing when I hear you
describe it.
>>Nick: Yeah, well it sounds like simply,
you know you have certain states which you
get into.
Like maybe just, you know, define it or as
constant in it, and you know, just call up
your current state and you know, so you can
say, at home "Set up button."
You know.
And you pass in your current state.
And you know, if you're in the root with those
you don't show it.
Something like that.
But yeah, I think you're basically gonna have
to manage it yourself.
>>Richard: So [inaudible]
>>Sparky: [inaudible] would be a good implementation
for that.
>>Nick: Say again, Sparky?
>>Sparky: I'm trying to think if you could
get some good UX by using the, a view pager
there.
And rather than just popping fragments in
and out of existence.
I don't know.
I'm sort of mulling over it.
>>Matt: You might be able to if you had, if
they weren't taking up the entire screen.
There could be some really weird stuff that
you could do with it but, not sure whether
it would make sense or not.
>>Nick: ViewPage doesn't have [inaudible]
>>Matt: Yeah, exactly.
So you could have sort of a third—yeah,
that would be interesting.
Could you dynamically change the width developments?
The ViewPage width?
>>Nick: Yeah, the page width on the adapters.
You could do that.
You could change it.
>>Sparky: Well, if you stick your fragments
in a linear layout, can you give them layout
widths?
Mm.
>>Nick: No, if it's in the ViewPager it wouldn't
respect that.
You'd have to use the set page width, which,
API on, Set, page, width.
The API on the page adapter I think.
>>Rich: Oh yeah.
>>Nick: But yeah.
Yeah, that's the question.
Um.
Yeah, I think essentially you're gonna have
to handle your own state.
So whatever you do, like join those callbacks
you talk about.
So when a fragment is talking to the activity
to do the fragment transactions, that's the
point at which you wanna kind of enable, save
all the app [unintelligible]
>>Richard: Yeah, so I think I've got something
to do that.
I wasn't sure it was the best way.
The other problem I'm having is about handling
the user pressing the up button.
'Cause I found various ways online, but it
just jumps the user straight back to the home
screen.
>>Nick: So you can override that with the,
in the activity, if you add override the option
item selected method.
And switch on the idea, I'm pretty sure it's
Android.r.id.home.
I think that's it.
>>Richard: Yeah, so I've implemented that
method and I'm checking for that case.
>>Nick: So you're saying that sometimes when
you hit the up button it's not going active?
>>Richard: Well, my slight question is, what
code should I be putting in there because
I found some example code online.
And um, what's OK, or I think I've got some
slightly bad code.
I've been using for the mobile stuff, which
works find.
But with the tablet layout, having the screens
side by side, I found some code about using
an intent.
And calling an intent.
But that always jumps the user back to the
–
>>Nick: Yeah, I think it [unintelligible]
you probably wanna be invoking your own callbacks
to do whatever any one state they're in, so.
>>Sparky: Right, it seems to me like that
on options menu, options item selected, is
where you want to look at your depth of detail
and remove the fragment and decrease the depth.
Or you know, change your state variable, whatever
that happens to be.
>>Richard: Yeah, I was thinking I have to
do something custom to deal with my own program
transactions.
I was just wondering if there was anything
better, a better way of doing it inbuilt.
But it sounds like the answer is "No."
>>Sparky: There's nothing particularly wrong
or hacky about using the fragment manager
to remove a fragment.
>>Richard: OK.
>>Rich: Great.
>>Sparky: I guess you could.
I mean you could allocate all of your fragments
statically and just show and hide them.
You just stick 'em in the XML and if you know
that there's exactly one of each, you could
hide it.
And then when you need to see it you could
populate it with the right stuff and show
it.
Um, I don't know.
It's another way to do it, I guess.
>>Richard: OK.
Thank you.
>>Rich: OK.
>>Sparky: I suppose if you statically create
them all then you don't ever need to actually
search for one.
You can just get the IDs of your fragments
and just access them directly.
Might be a little bit simpler that way, I
don't know.
>>Rich: OK, we've had another question dropped
into the Moderator.
From Weimar, as well.
So, um, we can have a quick look at that.
He posted his StackOverflow question and then
linked to it in the Moderator.
Which is great.
StackOverflow question is, "One of my activities
embeds a video view.
And on pausing and resuming, it's calling
OnPause and OnResume respectively but OnResume
is called before the activity is actually
visible to the user.
And it's happening when he presses the power
button to lock the device, and then presses
the power button again to unlock it.
OnResume gets called before the user unlocks
the screen.
This is something actually we've spoken about
quite a bit in terms of games.
Uh, "Games That Play Nice" was a talk that
Dan and Ian did.
And there's also a blog post on it.
>>Nick: [inaudible]
>>Rich: There was a blog post in there that
was also in there at the Google IO talk this
year.
You actually need to lock the OnResume and
the OnFocused changed event.
To say that you've gained focus again.
Because the lock screen, before Jellybean,
wasn't actually an activity.
It was just something that appeared on the
very top of the actual screen.
Your application became resumed.
But there was something still on top of it.
And it was only once the user unlocked it,
or got to that screen, you got the focus back
again.
But some, it's like complications.
In just waiting for OnFocus changed, or OnResumed.
So, you need to look for both of them.
But it's in the blog post.
I'll post it on the StackOverflow to explain
the exact blog post in there.
But you, yeah, it's a well-known issue.
And from Jellybean, it doesn't' exist anymore.
So if you test it on a new Galaxy Nexus or
a Nexus 7, you'll see it doesn't happen.
Because the lock screen has been changed.
>>Matt: Nice.
>>Sparky: Let's see, we have another question
from Paul in the chat here.
He wants to know "Can I use NFC to bootstrap
a Wi-Fi communication channel?"
Um, maybe?
Did we have that for Jellybean?
Do you know, can you use the--?
>>Nick: What kind of Wi-Fi communication?
You mean, like to [inaudible]
>>Sparky, no, I think he's talking about using,
yeah, using NFC beam to, or using Android
beam to initiate the transfer and then.
Oh, no that's not Wi-Fi.
That hands it over to Bluetooth for the bulk
transfer, doesn't it?
>>Nick: I don't think you can.
I think there's no programmatic way to turn
on Wi-Fi direct, if that's what you're talking
about.
I think it requires user intervention.
>>Sparky: There's, there's an emerging standard
for this, isn't there?
It's like sort of a, it's a recognized practice.
I just don't know if we've implemented it
yet.
I don't think we have.
>>Nick: Paul, can you be a bit more specific
about what you mean by Wi-Fi communication
channel.
What are you trying to do?
>>Matt: I've kind of got this image of someone
scanning an NFC card and then input in the
Wi-Fi password or something.
And turning it on.
And just—
>>Nick: I've thought about making an app like
that one.
You see the hacker farms, you walk up and
you [inaudible] the Wi-Fi.
>>Matt: But anyway [unintelligible] the settings
and there's some way you know to write the
actual pass code for that, the keyboard.
>>Nick: Which you can do.
>>Matt: Yeah.
That'd be pretty cool.
[Hangout dings]
[microphone interference sound]
[loud typing]
>>Rich: Hey there.
>>Sparky: Look like we've just been joined
by a new viewer, Lindon.
Hello, welcome to the hangout.
>>Lindon: Hi.
[loud microphone interference noises]
>>Sparky: is there anything you have to discuss
related to Android development?
What are you working on right now?
Do you have any questions?
[Hangout dings]
>>Nick: So Paul has provided more information
in the sidebar saying that he's basically
looking to transfer data.
As far as using NFC to kind of initiate the
connection.
And then [unintelligible] through Wi-Fi.
Well the good news is, as of Jellybean, that's
exactly what Android beam does for you.
So you get that for free.
So it will initiate a Bluetooth connection
through the two devices and send it via the
Bluetooth.
It doesn't use any form of Wi-Fi yet.
I know Samsung had rolled their own solution
there, I think.
S Beam or something.
Which [unintelligible] to Wi-Fi direct.
Which is good for them.
But at the moment the IP for Android platform
won't do that.
Um, so that's Jellybean onwards.
If you are trying to bring that back to older
devices like I guess Gingerbread or ICS, then
I imagine you could do that but you'd be setting
up an insecure Bluetooth connection.
But I would have to look into that.
Haven't tried it myself.
>>Rich: Yeah.
Yeah I don't know if there's any part of that
Bluetooth connection that would need the secure
part of the system.
>>Nick: I think, yeah.
>>Rich: But you can have a Bluetooth zero
connection actually without the user's [inaudible].
>>Nick: I think it also needs the exchange
there, the NFC. 'cause most of the NFC stuff
is about pushing your way.
And where this is an opportunity to exchange
like [inaudible] or whatever.
[inaudible]
>>Sparky: Yeah.
Of course NFC is just a great way to transmit
a shared secret because it works over such
a short range.
So that's why it's ideal for bootstrapping
something like a Wi-Fi or Bluetooth connection.
>>Rich:[inaudible]
>>Sparky: Alright.
ViewPager with multiple pages on screen.
See Mark Murphy's recent blog post.
Cool.
Yeah.
>>Rich: Plus one.
[laughter]
>>Sparky: That was nice.
>>Rich: Well I saw a plus one thing in the
comments on the Google plus hangout.
There's a Google plus hangout.
You would have thought they would have had
plus one buttons, but.
You have to make them yourself.
>>Sparky: Yeah, it's a good idea.
But it looks almost suggestively obscene.
I don't know.
[laughs]
>>Nick: [inaudible] have any, it died and
there's a hangout so there's no URL to which
to go.
>>Rich: Are we up to ten?
>>Nick: So, have we answered everyone's questions?
>>Rich: Oh!
We've got another new one come in.
From "S" from Nowhere.
>>Nick: [inaudible] out.
>>Rich: Uh, it's a long one.
That's all right there.
"How do you make those one by one shortcut
widgets which link to other widgets?
But the one by one settings.
Also, is there a high level summary of these
somewhere?
I couldn't find anything in the API guides
search section?"
So, a one by one widget is just that.
You just give it out, well, like an icon.
One by one.
You [inaudible]
>>Nick: [inaudible]
[laughter]
>>Rich: Well, when you touch it, it files
an intent which launches the settings page.
You can see those intents often if you plug
the device, I don't know why I'm doing it.
Sorry, I'm not bored.
If you plug your device into your ADB long
cat.
It's often, when you press settings, you'll
see the settings intents file.
And you just need to file the same intent.
They're all listed.
So all the service intents documented as well.
So you can build them very quickly and usually
it's these one by one widgets.
For about five rows of code.
It's nice if you put different resolution
icons in there.
So people on different devices having the
ability to get them the best one.
And then touch it and file intent.
>>Nick: I don't quite get what you mean by
link to other widgets.
>>Rich: Mm. like the one by one settings.
Oh, do you think when you say, "settings"
and then it says, "do you want settings for
this, this, or this, or this?"
So, widget settings.
>>Nick: Yes.
Don't know.
>>Rich: Do we do that?
I think we do.
They did it on [inaudible]
>>Matt: [inaudible]
>>Rich: Yeah.
And if you drop it, it'll say then, yeah,
so that's just it.
>>Nick: That's just your configuration [inaudible]
>>Rich: Yep.
OK.
Does he mean the folder--?
>>Nick: Yeah, so basically the feature of
widgets which is when you picked it, and you
add it to the home screen, you can optionally
then have a configuration setup.
So, you supply this configuration activity.
At which point they can then pick what actually
you wanted to stay on that widget.
So that's, so check out the widget docs for
that configuration info.
>>Rich: Yes.
Just in case they are actually watching.
>>Nick: And are there any [inaudible] docs
anywhere.
Yes.
>>Rich: [laughs]
>>Nick: Are you?
>>Sparky: So I did get one more questions
in the Moderator.
Which said "Can you please look at this issue
in the IssueTracker?"
Which I'll go ahead and read.
He says, um "I override getchildstaticstransformation
to create my own transformations according
to locations.
The child I am drawing every child worked
fine before Jellybean but fails when hardware
acceleration is on."
Etcetera, etcetera.
And yeah, some canvas drawing operations are
not supported in hardware acceleration.
I don't know if this is one of them.
But every time I've reported something like
this to the guys on the engineering team,
the one who implemented it, usually Romain
Guy, says, "Oh yeah, that's not supported
in hardware acceleration.
Just turn off hardware acceleration and use
software rendering."
So I would say, in cases like this, if software
rendering is acceptable, then just you know,
bite the bullet and use that.
Otherwise, we can look into it and see if
it's a bug but it's probably not a bug.
So.
It's probably intentionally not hardware accelerated,
is my guess.
Let's see.
>>Nick: Hey Al, how's it going?
>>Al: Hey guys, pretty good.
I was trying to join using a mobile device
but was having no luck.
So I thought I'd go back to the PC.
[laughter]
>>Nick: Aw.
>>Rich: Oh dear.
It's a relatively new feature.
>>Al: I could hear you guys but I couldn't
see any video and couldn't broadcast audio.
Couldn't broadcast video.
But as you say, it's early days, so.
>>Rich: Wow.
>>Al: I did get one, uh, basically, more than
five second delay.
So it was wanting to report a "application
not responding."
So I put that through.
Hopefully things will get better.
[laughter]
>>Nick: [unintelligible]
>>Rich: Oh.
>>Nick: You got any questions this week, Al,
or are you just hanging out?
>>Al: I'm just hanging out.
I've been playing with the multi window stuff
on the Samsung Note, so—
>>Nick: Cool.
>>Al: It's, I've been doing a bit of delving
into it and it's written in a way that potentially
could appear in a future version of Android
if I guess all the legal guys work it out
and it's all deemed acceptable.
So it could be useful little bit of technology.
>>Nick: So I've not actually tried it yet.
So this is in the Galaxy Note ten, one.
Right?
And you said it's also present in the S three
which lets you have two apps on the screen
at once, right?
>>Al: Yeah, basically splits the ten inch
screen in two.
So when you've got it in landscape mode, you
can have one app on the left and one app on
the right.
And they get equal spacing.
But it's only for a certain select few applications.
Which are part of the stock firmware.
Um, the reason behind that, is there's a lot
of private APIs that are used to firstly detect
whether it's, the functionality to do two
apps on the screen at once is present.
And secondly actually to implement the switch
between the dual screen mode and single screen
mode.
>>Nick: So is it, well my concern is, it's
not really a dual screen mode.
It's, one app that's actually--
[loud unintelligible talking from other hangout
participants]
>>Al: Sorry Nick, I lost you there, mate.
I just got—
>>Nick: So my concern, like I said I've not
played with it.
But I've only seen, this is all based on the
Burgess feature review of the ten one note.
It looked like one app was kind of paused
and one app was kinda running.
So that if you tried to switch back and forth
there'd be like a, I don't know, what, you
kind of like unpause the other application,
you run back to the other, had to unpause
that one, and—
>>Al: It, from what I can see, the judder
doesn't seem to be noticeable.
It may be that only one is active at any one
time and certainly when dialogs pop up they
can be modal dialogs.
You can't switch to the other app and leave
the modal dialog on one of them.
It takes control of the whole screen.
It's, it may be pausing it.
I would suspect it is.
But it's nothing that's sort of a severe judder
on most of the switches.
I guess that's something that they've sorted
out recently.
'Cause there was one firmware update I've
had for it so far.
>>Rich: Interesting.
[Hangout dings]
>>Nick: Well, I did see they are using the
Android name space.
They've just gone right in there, and added
the Android name space.
>>Al: [laughs] Yeah, they've used Android.sec.
Samsung electrical corporation.
So they're trying to tuck it away in their
own little area.
But the way it's written, the actual multi
window, window manager is very similar to
the window manager that already exists in
Android.
So my, from looking at the S3 firmware as
well, it looks very much like they're using
this as a base part of all of their Ice Cream
Sandwich and Jellybean firmwares.
And this is why I think it's a potential for
being upstreamed and put into the IO SP at
some point.
Because the way it's written, it wouldn't
involve a lot of changes for most applications.
To make use of it.
>>Nick: Interesting.
So, it makes an interesting scenario is where
an app going from a full window into a half
window, like what new configuration do they
get notified.
>>Rich: I assume it switches to portrait.
>>Al: Yeah, it does.
It does.
It switches to portrait.
And it's, it's exactly the same as you've
got, an orientation rotation.
So it's--
>>Nick: Yeah?
It was the pad phone I guess was one of the
first devices that you know, had those quite
drastic changes in configuration and most
apps just died.
Don't they?
When you plug the phone into the tablet.
>>Al: The Sony P series is exactly the same
thing.
That's the one with the two screens and the
clamshell design.
You've got a button on the task bar which
allows you to make apps on both screens or
limited them to one.
And even stuff like Google Music was crashing
originally.
So, it's there's stuff to be wary of.
But from what I've seen of the framework stuff.
And looking at some of the way they've implemented
it, it looks almost the same as any app would
get, by being put on a phone and twisted in
orientation.
So most apps, most well written apps, should
be able to handle it a lot easier than the
kind of huge change in dimensions that was
present when you were using things like the
P Series and the Pad Phone and stuff like
that.
>>Nick: Interesting.
>>Al: Yeah, it will be interesting to see
how it goes.
>>Rich: Were you just dissecting it first,
though?
>>Al: I was.
It's one of those things that I've been working
with some devices that do TV's and when you've
got the space for a TV, having two apps on
the screen at once is quite possible.
So it was interesting to see whether it could
be an Android driven device.
And doing those two things on screen at once.
>>Matt: IT would be interesting to see what
it does with intents.
Like open intents have started becoming a
lot more feasible, you can then just start
launching apps on the others.
So it comes a part of your app and then starts
communicating on the same sort of basis.
Like at the same time.
Be kind of cool.
>>Al: It would be brilliant.
At the moment, all that happens is when you
select multiscreen you get the drop down list
of like five or six apps.
And you select which other one you want to
go in the pane.
So it's limited like that.
But yeah.
That would be a really cool—
>>Nick: [inaudible] those apps are Samsung
Mail, Samsung Browser, not Gmail and Chrome.
>>Al: The browser is actually the Android
stock browser with very small amount of tweaks.
I did a quick comparison of some of the classes.
And most of the tweaks seem to be in the UI
rather than anything more fundamental.
And that's literally because the way they've
implemented it, they've put in the action
bar the button to go between multi-screen
and single screen mode, rather than making
it part of the strip bar at the bottom where
the most of the buttons, most of the settings
are.
>>Nick: Well, it's decompiling framework.Java
for fun and profit.
[laughter]
>>Nick: So I think that pretty much brings
us to the end of our time.
>>Rich: Yeah.
If we didn't get to answer your question today,
but I think we got through most of them.
Um, same time next week.
Don't know if there's anything special on
next Wednesday?
Um, thank you all for joining us today in
the hangout.
And answering such, answering?
Asking such good questions.
[laughs]
>>Matt: Thanks guys.
>>Nick: Yep.
>>Sparky: Answering, too.
>>Matt: Cheers.
Bye, everyone.